welcome back to Las Vegas now and
today's legal minute we are learning
what are some of the benefits of
reporting a work injury Eric Palacios
from Eric Palacios and Associates the
sponsors of this segment tell us more
hi I'm Eric Palacios this week's
question is what are the benefits of
reporting a work injury
there are three main reasons number one
medical treatment reporting a work
accident promptly will ensure that you
receive medical attention right away
number two workers compensation benefits
reporting a work accident is a necessary
step in getting workers compensation
benefits which will cover the cost of
your medical treatment lost wages and
compensation for permanent disabilities
number three legal protection reporting
a work accident will also protect your
rights as it provides a record of the
incident that can be used as evidence in
any future legal proceedings this could
be especially important in order to get
compensation for permanent injuries or
disabilities remember if you don't
report a work injury you risk losing all
your workers compensation rights if you
suffer a work injury report it and call
an attorney right away
give Eric Palacios and Associates a call
or visit their website at Eric
palacioslaw.com we'll be right back from
Las Vegas now